une production du studio sfr
bienvenue au sans fil le podcast où on
parle ce qu'on règle nos invités date si
tu cherches quentin avec moins d'hommes
plantes si vous voulez louer l'espace
dans lequel on se trouve le boudoir le
boudoir au studio sfr il est maintenant
disponible pour vous cette offre
décontractée pour des conversations one
on one avec une qualité
absolue bien confort merveilleux aussi
on s'occupe de tout on s'occupe du
matériel on a la technique pour vous
faites venir ici pensez à votre concept
à vos idées jaser on vous envoie tout
sur deux jours après pour plus d'infos
du sf fois ci à 7 secondes
cette semaine on reçoit karim el niño
qui est préparateur physique entre états
de jim est un activiste pour la
promotion de la santé de l'entraînement
de bonnes habitudes de vie il a lancé un
jour de mouvements de protestation
pacifiques
en fait il y avait l'idée d'ouvrir son
jim de 30 janvier dernier
[Musique]
pour envoyer un message symbolique en
fait qui puisse faire autant sur
l'important centre de l'activité
physique dans notre société tout dans la
lutte contre contre des problèmes de
santé en général qui c'est pas
intéressant de l'entendre parler c'est
un dico cependant on sait juste pas
intéressant on a parlé de on est tous
soient faites vous le savez les grands
défenseurs de l'activité physique
c'était intéressant savoir c'est quoi
son message puis ces coquilles qu'est-ce
que son message des tpo aussi seront
défaits distinction fait que ça mais en
fait c'est de rencontrer un coloris
négoce parlophone 1 go un vrai bon
craquer toujours le fun
ok merci qu'à une pièce on va les
remercier notamment du temps intéressant
vous laisse à la conversation n'ont pas
de casque
le podcast est présenté par sochaux
richert qui se chargent sur sharks et
les fournisseurs de vpn ckoi et vpn ça
vous permet d'échanger virtuellement
votre location sur internet donc ça ça
pue fait remettre ce matin une série un
film que vous savez qui est sortie si le
aller sur et netflix aux autres qui est
pas disponible a dit une petite pénible
dans votre location ça veut dire qu'ils
quittent foundem et on adore mais pas au
québec saw 6 frais sera moins lourde au
d'une fois j'étais dans un autre pays
puis moi avant de me coucher du coup
toujours mon petit bio fils
disponibles imagine la panique que j'ai
vécu si j'avais surcharge bpm j'aurais
pu écouter mon titi a fait ça manouche
points puis un vpn aussi ça sert à
naviguer sur des raisons public de façon
plus sécuritaire donc par exemple si
vous êtes souvent sur la route que vous
êtes dans des ouailles faille à gauche à
droite un vpn le vpn sur ce choc en fait
vous permettent d'être plus sécuritaire
dans votre connexion si vous êtes un
étudiant qui allait souvent dans des cas
free même principe sur chaque offre une
énorme promotion pour vous si vous
voulez vous voulez l'utiliser le code
promo qu'on a c'est le sans fil en un
mot tenez vous bien pour l'offre qui
s'en vient gay si vous êtes assis rester
assis si vous êtes debout assise et vous
êtes assis couché vous si vous êtes dans
votre voiture arrêtez vous sur le côté
qu'est le code promo sans filtre en un
mot pour 83 % de rabais et 3 mois
gratuits tant qu'assuré vous le donne
québec pour pouvoir changer
virtuellement d'adressent et pour
pouvoir naviguer de façon plus
sécuritaire ce choc allez voir le site
dans la déception de podcasts de promo
sans fil en un mot se charge chaque jour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
yes merci d'être là le plaisir mais ça
vous me verrez vite et légumes plaisir
non c'est drôle parce que hier j'ai
comme j'ai acheté j'ai parlé tout à dom
t on s'en était déjà parlé avec mon
devoir parler mais avec l'histoire de
jim plus l'ouverture des jam et tout ce
qui ya ma soeur et moi écrit parce que
ma soeur me vois toujours décidé
d'inviter à savoir sur le podcast puis à
m'envoyer hier 2 2 invités puis tu étais
dans les invités qui me proposait on
venait d'en parler le
s'appelle sarah mono remercie
sincèrement merci c'est vraiment de la
russie 62 les écoute pas tous les votes
car
si je suis rendue jusqu'à sarah-maude
ouais ouais
ça qu'un voyage vers un modèle est en
train d g soit le profil c'est sa maman
et 100 à 130 athlètes là elle a fait la
fête la natation avant lui a fait
l'été a fait beaucoup de stand-up parole
a fait j'ai regardé des activités comme
ça ce supporter se
fout de ça ça transcende les milieux
parce que tu es dans mon milieu je suis
très dans le cross training préparation
physique le stade du monde qui sont dans
d'autres supports piqué c'est vraiment
ressenti dans tous les sports du mont
d'or qui est moi je peux pas je vois la
balle
comme je t'ai pas prier
moi je lançais ce petit jeu mais je me
marre offrons sécurité mais je pensais
pas
au moment où on se parle en fait le
haillan non c'est qu'ils aiment à les
rouvrir comme dans deux semaines imagine
que c'est quand même un soulagement pour
un propriétaire de gym comme toi ouais
franchement amer en fait on soulagement
à main
je disais matin justement ce que me
quantique quantis fait la job de faire
un cadeau aux emballages une grosse
boîte le mans c'est un petit cadeau
comme ça c'est on le savait que on
arrête à quelques apports
si on avait su on n'était pas sorti sur
mac qui nous aurait dit le 3 mars fait
peut-être qu'on vient de s'acheter deux
semaines de plus ouais c'est vraiment
cool pour tout le monde on a deux
semaines de plus mais dans le langage
qui est utilisé ne comprend que
ils y ont écouté à moitié dans ce sens
que le message était pas juste ouvrir
les centres d'entraînement c'était
vraiment et on a un problème de société
puis il faudrait mettre la la la santé
en premier peu importe la décision du
prince et que le paradigme qui
utilisaient en ce moment dans la prise
de décisions puis d'en haut niveau de la
gestion gouvernementale la santé pas
pris en considération parce que si
c'était le cas il y aurait été capable
de faire des concessions d'ici palevo le
physio puis te faire traiter quand une
blessure puis devrait être capable de
pouvoir avoir la séance privée si jamais
tu reviens d'une blessure tu en as
besoin de ta santé mentale et se fait
que c'était plus seul le point les
stérols à la santé doit en premier puis
nous ôtons doit faire partie de la
solution donc la prochaine décision ce
serait le 7 février on a compris le
message il faut que ça avance des
seconds font se disent pas ce qu'on a
entendu si vous allez entendre deux
semaines pour vous ouvrir les jeans
prise parce
que c'est bon on t'a pas très compris
lorsque je vois artistes
reculer un petit peu avant ce parce que
je veux tu m'expliques moi je veux être
le premier à aller au jam camp qui vont
réouvrir joue avec la marche le premier
à ma bonne image est abonné aux canaux
finesse je vais depuis depuis que j'ai
fini de faire de la natation public eu
accès à la salle de sport du rouge et or
dans le forez ou trois fois par semaine
et
josiane trois fois par semaine puis puis
je vais être la première tournée austro
que ça va ouvrir moi j'ai eu le
ton banc quand la pandémie tomber le
confinement tout est fermé moi j'ai eu
le réflexe vraiment simple de courir
dehors pour faire des ombres cas depuis
j'ai jamais ressenti et et je trouve ça
plate quand il faisait moins 20 d'être
obligés d'aller courir dehors mais
tombait jamais ressenti le besoin
intrinsèque d'aller au gym puis de ce
que je comprends du t2 de la vidéo que
te fais du message que tu en vois c'est
que les gens il ya plus que juste le
désir de faire
l'activité physique parce que ce désir
là peut être comblée dans n'importe
quelle autre cette offre comme jim peux
tu m'expliquer vraiment c'est quoi ce
besoin là c'est quoi la nécessité
l'ouverture des jam considérant qu'ils
peuvent par l'activité physique à
l'extérieur d'un tueur marc dumas 4
heures et 6 1% pour ça parce que je
donne même profil que toi en fait si
j'avais pas accès aux soins
d'entraînement je m'entraînerai par moi
même je suis complètement de reggane
endorphines nous tirons les tout des
athlètes si une journée sans m'entraîner
sur ma faim je deviens gré c'est
super mais pas trop si je suis un autre
personne le mode de trois jours comme ça
ça m'a pas panther affecter une zone
depuis notre tendre enfance on fait du
sport on a une éducation qui prenait
vers le sport fait que c'est sûr qu'il
ne veut pas on est on est comme un grain
processus là de tous les jours on doit
bouger pour sentir bien notre poupée
dansante et puis on est éduqué dans
notre sport pour faire la performance
aussi fait connaître on a appris à
s'entraîner par nous mêmes pièces
provenant
d'environnements favorables fait que tu
nous mets n'importe où ou en vacances
pas de son entraînement sur la beach on
est capable de dire à qui on va faire
dix minutes ce ce panel seconde saison
c'est dans notre adn
mais la majorité de la population
de plus en plus tu vois qu'ils y ont
besoin de quelqu'un qui va non seulement
les aider les diriger pour que ce soit
efficace pousse à rentrer dans le temps
avec de plus en plus je réalise que les
gens faut que ça soit faut pas que ce
soit time consuming ils veulent pas se
casser la tête ils veulent plus penser
parce que tout est automatisé fait
qu'ils veulent aller au sein
d'entraînement qu'est ce que je dois
faire ceci ou amap let's go après une
heure s'est fait ce sera ta maison tu
peux continuer à arrêter productivité
cinquième mois si ces gens là que je
reçois majoritairement dans son
entraînement fait que si ces gens là qui
ont besoin direction parce que ici sont
programmables de le faire sont capables
de le faire mais on sera là ils n'ont
pas la motivation alphand par eux mêmes
à la maison et ont besoin d'aller à
l'extérieur la maison pour le fin
ça vient aussi rejoint tout ces gens là
qui ont pas eu cette éducation l'autre
nous autres je pense à met l'emphase sur
un point qui est super important c'est
comme faut qu'on change notre système
d'éducation par rapport à seul faut
qu'on soit capable dans les gens plus
autonome puis surtout faucon qu'on mette
plus l'accent sur le sport dans notre
système d'éducation le fait que ça va
vraiment loin j'ai réalisé par la
pandémie ajouté qu'un bon bain les gens
ils peuvent s'entraîner la maison cool
c'est mais la merci des gens ils savent
pas comment le bombay achetait le
programme que les causes où il faisait
la maison près qu'ils ont appris à
s'entraîner à la maison ils ont tripé
let's groove la case mois qu'on se marre
faire découvrir la maison après germaine
on gagne sortie de chivhu l'antico
puis l'autre partie si bas qu'il faut
que tu prennes par la main il faut que
tu ailles chercher ben zotti on l'ait
pas
fait c'est quand je parle de refaire le
système d'éducation c'est que c'est un
peu comme on va dire que de quatre
projets que tu roules à 25% chacun si on
entrepreneuriaux le savez autant que moi
si vous voulez à 25 pour ça fait que
c'est ce que si on met de l'éducation
fait ducation physique à 2 cos neuf
jours secondaire fort probablement que
notre éducation à la santé va prendre
une chute fortement que les gens sont
pas munis pour pouvoir s'entraîner fait
que je pense qu'on a toutes une refonte
affaire qui va de très loin d'un thé
ducation là j'avais j'avais cette
réflexion le 26 août on ne peut pas
vraiment manqué d'éducation physique
parce qu'on est en sport études mais
j'avais cette réflexion là justement
pour des jeunes qui étaient au régulier
ou dans une dans une école standard qui
dépensent par est nécessairement cours
d'éducation physique puis cours
d'alimentation pendant tout son parcours
seconde 1 primaire secondaire même
univers cégep collégiale il y en a pas
des courses d'alimentation puis les
cours d'éducation physique sont vraiment
restreint et la hausse équipe c'est sûr
que comme
l'éducation physique on t'apprend comme
les bases du jam bien c'est quand même
c'est quand même assez restreint
alimentation c'est quand juste ignorée
comme tout au long de ta formation alors
que il me semble que c'est capital
d'avoir au moins une base dans notre
vision pour la santé globale
% simple fait que l'école te rendre plus
habilités à faire dans la vie et puis à
la base mais c'est ça c'est du club du
mans je le dis en fait qu on a des co
primaires dans l'éducation physique
maintenant tu vas voir gens là dessus de
vie l'alimentation
mais il faudrait comme tu dis que ce
soit beaucoup plus approfondie 100% jeu
100% d'accord avec toi
puis c'est ce que comme tu disais au
niveau de l'éducation physique c'est la
même chose c'est d'automne vécu je peux
citer chose pour vous le maître c'est
comme secondaire
basket ball badminton volley ball ça
recommence l'année prochaine puis le
citer qu'un pas de faire des tournées
marché bank 95 pour ça on est tous des
bonnes notes jusqu'à son physique sa
remontée notre note affrontés puis
l'autre jean exemple ma petite enquête
du genre
correctives mais qui qui vu qu'ils
étaient corrects mais elle n'a jamais eu
le sentiment de compétence sport va
gueuler après montage foudre j'arrête de
faire du sport c'est en plus j'ai
toujours été en moyenne pour coacher
free fait que c'est quelqu'un qui vit qu
ce système le bail il faut lâcher le
sport rapidement maintenant ce qu'ils
font c'est qu'avec la
refonte du système d'éducation puis le
système de compétences au niveau
d'éducation mais les codifications
physiques sont beaucoup plus intégrative
s'est pas vraiment comme le jeune au
milieu qui vont pouvons vraiment
développer selon leur qualité petite
soeur mais nous ce qu'on a vécu ce nos
décideurs publics c'est ce qu'ils ont
vécu ou ci dessus avec de l'entraînement
qu'est ce que ce rappel c'était jean le
test bip avis on vend des machines
outils fait que c'est pour ça qu'en soit
monde un peu pris avec cette idéologie
là parce que les décideurs c'est ce
qu'ont vécu
des bêtes dont peut-être pas embarquer
là-dedans aux autres pour le vécu ici
mais maintenant à l'entraînement c'est
de l'antique ce qui est vraiment
populaire que ce qui qui la
transformation qc l'entraînement
fonctionnel encore fonctionner ce qui
est notre succès c'est super éducatif 1
c'est super attrayant pour les jeunes ce
parfum dé des circuits l on sort
complètement du l'homme que nous au
tourneur on a vécu et je pense qu'à
quelque chose de super cool à développer
là dessus qu'il faut que soit mis de
l'avant
en éducation physique que ce soit au
primaire au secondaire au cégep vraiment
attirer l'attention puis pour aussi
augmenter le sentiment de compétence des
gens parce que tout le monde est
compétent l'entraînement indien même si
tu sais il te reproche mais de fait
capable aujourd'hui d'apprendre à faire
un squat ne demande pas de mettre une
baffe à 225 les jeux mais juste de
devenir le fait que je pense que c'est
vraiment voir ce qu'il faut qu'on aille
dans notre société niveau d'éducation le
rang des gens compétition comme
intéressant le point la compétence le
j'avais jamais vu seul même je me
rappelle au cégep justement du dans ce
cours le faisant un test au début un
test afin selon l'amélioration d'un
autant dépens des mets au début
si tu faisais pas de temps c'était
impossible pour toi d'avoir 100 afin
ferme et on savait même pas de lien avec
l'amélioration que tu avais c'est quand
arrivait dans le court tu avais déjà une
limite notre gré de faire dix prochains
sept mètres cette limite est déjà la
note maximale afin que ça rien avoir la
compétence et le savoir avec ja tout
était poche fait qu est ou non mais
jamais jamais accéder ou plus au tour à
jamais avoir en plus de sa médication
physique parce que ta guise que tes
poches puis c'est un cours obligatoire
que tout le monde a besoin de fonds et
puis mais surtout si par rapport aux
cours que j'ai fait une session à
donington cg mais c'est judith von et au
badminton jeux septembre parce que tout
ce qui habille était vraiment les pieds
de sigean n'est ce pas le jeu super moto
est un peu moyen
je suis conne mais au final c'est pas
mal ce que moi puis les grands majorité
de membres d'écho de badminton ont pu
rendre avoir touché au badminton après
pis c'est le collectif est ce que l'on
faisait que ça ça devrait être décidé
d'implémenter quelque chose qui vont
résister à près de pontivy éviter de
donner les outils à quelqu'un pie ix
aussi de montrer l'importance de comme
avoir cette bonne hygiène de vie l'appui
de bouger comme de façon régulière pour
que ça reste après ouais ouais ça pour
ça c'est exactement ça c'est exactement
cet exemple le tarif puis sont en cours
mais des gens qui guérit poche 6 jamais
continuer après ça c'est démotivant
souvent je fais le parallèle avec savais
qu'avec mes entraîneurs cij a dit comme
super important quand quelqu'un quand tu
va coacher il faut qu'ils donnent une
victoire à tout le monde à chaque os et
commence pas à aller chercher 3 4 points
pour un critère de réussite peut être
qu'on travaille si j'y trouve qu'il faut
qu'il réussisse à voir
5,60 sa journée champion du monde mais
il est champion du monde pendant cinq
fois par semaine colline il va vouloir
continuer mais je pense que l'éducation
physique on développe des compétences
motricity sommes au delà tout ça il faut
qu'on construise la confiance agent août
les jeunes qui sont là c'est en faisant
ça on reste accroché d'un support
instituts tels que cette génération là
qui va revivre décideurs publics s'ils
vont mettre la santé en premier parce
que tu gueven ses jambes elle fait
l'éducation physique c'est pourtant le
sport la santé l'alimentation
je pensais de sa vie un problème avec
toi le but de ta prise de parole s'était
fait passer ce message le prince
charmant ou aussi du must imagine que tu
ferais ouvrir comme n'importe quel père
du djembé réouvrir mais comme n'importe
quel business qui fermait comme toi qui
est fermé sauf que l'essentiel ton
message c'est ce qu'il faut dans la
société valorisée plus sélectif il
exactement faut valoriser la santé en
premier dans notre décision puis
l'activité physique l'entraînement se
fait partie de la solution
je me dis quelque chose ça m'a fait
flasher lumière mais j'ai oublié ma moto
revenir oui c'est sûr c'est que oublier
en tant qu'entreprise au début c'était
plus c'est parce qu'on était jusqu à
gauche que ce parce que ce qu'on fait
des loyers le loyer fixé
le qu'evra qui vous implanter sa soeur
acheter les acheter un casque watts pour
les 16 personnes dans le cochon en toi
les dépenses et le tchèque d'autres sans
entraînement plex glaxo part de
plexiglas ok
puis là on fait un petit bout de chemin
là dedans l'on dise on le fait on
pleurait faire si oui c'est de l'argent
mais c'est de l'argent si si ça ça ça
s'enlève sa série bild ça se transforme
ça se prononce et puis on n'est pas dans
notre gestion des projets en régie
projet bm monte vite dans les bacs
j'espère l'onu danville fait que
l'effectif ça ne met pas dans manon
jacques conservateur puis on est bien
content que ce fait à chaque fois une
fermeture ouverture plus avancé plomb ce
questionnaire de crime d'un problème au
dos au delà de l'entreprise c'est
vraiment le message qui est envoyé qui
était un dessein l'expression considéré
le message qu'ont envoyé là on va
utiliser le fait qu'on ait fermé pour
des étalons on veut réorienter tout seul
il faut que ça passe au niveau politique
et il est souvent l'exemple du fameux
djembé québec lundi que l'éclosion
porter comme vraiment été la tête de la
turquie à droite ça a été comme tu es
vraiment l'étiquette mort ont le bac
j'ai cru comprendre
que je me suis fait longtemps qu'ils
étaient voix de les préjugés par rapport
à béton ou jim qui par rapport au monde
cent trente petits ouais c'est quoi
maintenant ce à quoi le préjugé yéyé
jusqu'à quand cette annonce je me tirait
les cheveux un petit peu parce que kylie
jim vont réouvrir le stage hors du monde
qui fondent l'elliptique du monde chez
ce prêt sur machine gens exactement tout
ce que nous ont fait pas mais que je
comprends qu'il se fait encore aussi
dans décembre parce que oui on utilise
des machines c'est correct pour mauvais
c'est juste que l'image que ça projette
sur la même heure c'est fini le ti la
préparation physique et années 80 le
temps faisait des machines de maintenant
dans la pub mais le dirigeant ultra
fonctionnel agde système de poulie de
l'haltéro
bouger avec ton corps de cardio
vasculaire à fond avec plein de machines
de cardio vasculaires qui n'existait pas
avant avec l'image et comblement
différentes gerber bus vous lis qui me
donne une annonce de queyries presse qui
s'en prennent à sentir mes jean ccme
radio armure quel genre
c'est mon grand père qui s'entraînent
sur sa machine peut pas
le premier projet c'est les machines
deuxième préjugés c'est le gros su agen
devant le miroir mais de belles et
remplacé puis toutes les touches c'est
puis surtout genre puisqu'il douchebags
en arrosoir voyage transmanche comme
j'ai deux centres d'entraînement et
sociaux d'art dans la tête vont penser
j'enchaîne douchebag position
[Rires]
comme si je fais de grosses et des
plantes a fait du crossfit d'antongil
puis c'est pas la chose que je suis par
le plus du fait que je fais du crossfit
mettons pas ce qu'était mouche attiches
dans l'artichaut la musique j'ai pas mal
d'amis dans mon cercle qui font du cros
et de temps que sa part le monde à qui
je m'entraîne que je veux juste james et
puis pourtant c'est quand même une
partie assez importante de ta vie
garantit pas encore une fois soumis
réseaux sociaux je sais pas pourquoi
c'est vraiment le problème et d'y être
moi mais
là c'est comme un hit fait du crossfit
mais je fais toujours mon crossfit se
pose pas chaque jour levé
le pied comme moi mon expérience et
comme chaque fois que j'allais lui le
monde était cool c'était pas de gros
page 2 chaises puis des grosses
conversations des colons les gens disent
tout et internet a été le chalet les jim
je veux à québec
que cette crise est 5 fois seb le coach
full night for intelligent je sais que
je peux parler tout avec tf1
c'est juste drôle en fait il ya encore
vraiment
des stéréotypes qui font encore présenté
au final faire du sport cc c'est juste
positif c'est juste du plaisir fou rire
doigts pour porter pour la santé pour
ton moudre pour tenter ici je sais ce
que j'aime pas comprendre le
vieil vient du crossfit lui-même en
france se sont tirés dans le pub virale
à l'histoire c'est que ça qu'on
commençait à linverse à la place de
commencer à regarder un nouveau sport
qui s'appelle je ne sais pas le speed
ball tient la place de dire voici tu
peux je peux jouer dans un parc avec
plusieurs amis c'est super accessible et
plus vu des vidéos du parc jarry mal à
faire avec ma soeur et ma famille un
pique nique hanna fathy les autres
imaginent suspects devraient commencer
avait commencé avec ce genre d ali triki
speech par tous genres avec une ambiance
de malade du feu partout pierre c'est
quand je serai convaincu son genre
vraiment franche c'est pas capable et
les crossfit ce qu'ils ont fait et on
commence et que l'écran suit bien nous
montrer des affaires jean surhumain
dépassement de soi juste pour les
athlètes qui sont prêts à avoir des
sensations fortes fait que tu oses tu
avais tu avais fini sa carrière de mon
genre autant de
malades était déjà bon parce que tu es
un bon cardio puis tout l'intérêt des
gens peinent en compétition c'est un peu
ça notre histoire du jour des quantités
exactes lettres qui sont arrivés pour
l'été jean li lé les guinéens du
crossfit pendant trois quatre cinq ans
on a toutes les affaires inimaginable le
stupide que tu imagines entraînement
puis s'est forgé été
mais on en a vécu ce moment là ça a duré
cinq heures 10 jan 2011 à 2005 mais cinq
ans dans le milieu de l'entraînement ce
carré blond ça fait son chemin avec les
gens y ont associé
un monde qui prennent ce qu'ils font ça
va être intense puis voilà tout les
préjugés on est content vidal milieu en
2016 on voulait juste comme cassis et
barrières l'artisanat non la maintenance
est accessible à tout le monde fait que
l'organe aux réseaux sociaux si tu veux
jamais voir un athlète le synode pagis
tout un genre monsieur madame tout le
monde qui s'entraîne si je peux te dire
le moins possible d'abord pour vraiment
enlever cette association là on est
vraiment à ce genre de paradigme de
développement puis d'accessibilité
maintenant puis affronter plus dans la
performance mais ils vont tout le temps
se faire commencer là dessus parce que
eux-mêmes ne pense pas là mais
ils vont quand même envoyé ce message
loupe sont fiers au québec on est
différents dépôts comme si on est faits
qui ont devancé comme dit ceci de cette
image l'apprend créé une nouvelle qui
que plusieurs centres aussi vont à cette
direction le fait que j'imagine qu'avec
le temps ça va changer
association il y avait moi quand j'ai eu
une expérience fut brève avec le
crossfit de dans le sens où il ya eu une
année que j'ai pris of de natation puis
j'étais allé une fois dans un sens de
crosse fils
clairement tout est formé pour entraîner
des gens pour le guettait le
ski est que chaque mois avec mon
parcours d'athlète à meilhan étudiant en
littérature fait zéro en qui nous en
préparation ou en intervention sportive
j'ai acheté plus formée que lui le
j'arrive le puits le training c max
chine à
une minute max 1h01 match ne fait que 3
fois maximum mais
c'est pas max iops
fini mais le lendemain un carat de
déplier l'hébreu ouais mais genre blessé
le j'étais incapable de boue j'ai
pendant un bon une semaine où il suit
miles des fonds s'ils étaient jusque là
qu'il m'a vu arriver en sodium de
crossfit 0 formés pour comme
amener les gens vers le plaisir de
pratiquer
méfaits se fait juste moi j'ai apprécié
jusqu'à vraie fausse garde le crous
liszt et des malades est
célébré le sud est des des problèmes
avec ceux avec le cross training camp
c'est arrivé vraiment massivement un peu
monsieur n'importe qui qui qui
s'improvisait coach est arrivé sous ça
prenait vraiment une certification c'est
vraiment un problème dans mon milieu
naturel le passé en fait s'ouvrait un
centre affilié crossfit par exemple
suivre une formation d'une fin de
semaine en semaine fonctionnement on
sent que c'est trop beaucoup une bonne
semaine de tonton papiers après tu
pourrais t'on santé la formation
continue qui te ferait tous et toutes
ses inquiétudes à avoir quelqu'un pour
jenson croire suit l'élève au 1,2 trop 8
à pied puis tout métier qui n'ont pas de
pas de formation continue comme
universitaire collégial ou plus longue
période de temps c'est fait que où c'est
un problème à ce niveau là je crois que
ces gens là qui vous des cendres
continuent et engagent des gens qui sont
les landes et le lot ils savent que
maintenant la barre est haute au niveau
là au niveau du coaching la formation
effectifs voire des kinésiologues dans
ces endroits le fait que de plus en plus
souvent dans des endroits où est ce que
tu vas avoir des bonnes terres
d'entraînement qui sont là
fait que mais c'est quand même un
problème puis c'est quand même un
mystérieux de l'entraînement parce que
s'étant
déjà des bacs autant taureaux des gens
qui vont faire des certifications une
fin de semaine qui a accumulé leurs
potes tout avoir
tu peux avoir des kinésiologues qui sont
ce qu'ils sont formés mais qui sont pas
de temps compétent pour des entraves
plein de certification de sané qui sont
super compétent
fait quand même cela doit être moi j'ai
55 ans chez nous le ping mais mes temps
plein et non pas de bac en kinésiologie
le sait
mais c'est des gens qui sont ultra
compétente qui ont fait du terrain à
fond qui m'ont suivi qui ont suivi
d'autres gens effectivement pas force
d'être dans la place seule semaine
d'apprentissage contre conduit informé
de cette lettre après l'essai de voir
des affaires pitou fait que
effectivement c'est un problème dans le
milieu puis la vie du poète fait
justement oui ça fait en sorte que vu
qu'il y avait des gens qui étaient pas
décemment compétents ballotté des
blessures sont arrivés tout et tout j'ai
qui ont travaillé beaucoup dernièrement
aussi le procès pour démontrer que le
taux de niveau de la sécurité est plus
élevé que le taux de blessure l'a
donc c'est vrai tu peux toujours plus de
chances de blessés sujet par exemple je
sais pas au rugby otomo de frisbee ou
changements de direction rapides notre
adresse un espace contrôlé dans le même
même pendant l'entraînement fixée c'est
moins risqué sa cause des
personnes qui faisaient la course est
dangereux
oui il ya un an mais moins que savoir
cela
aujourd'hui
ton acte de désobéissance civile qui
était d'ouvrir d'enfants vous avez
ouvert les 32 villes oui on en fait on
voulait ouvrir au complet le transit ce
qu'on ne couvrir soit on ouvre on fait
des cours de groupe à l'intérieur de sa
détention puis qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
ce qui s'est passé c'est que
au début on était plusieurs à avoir émis
l'intention de
le savant cep l'europe l'été commence à
baky of disons mais la dame et
subventions jour son estimation la
municipalité c'est écrit que si j'ai la
mangue dans la ligne d'une protestation
je me faire enlever mais subventions je
peux pas fait que désolée de me retirer
ok c'est bon parfait je comprends
d'autant leur peau cette subvention le
fait qu'on s'est dit ouvert aux nouveaux
appareils puis le message commence à
cheminer puis le samedi soir jean 8
heures on voit un tweet le d'une
journaliste de cbc radio can 2010 est
que le mystère de gaulle sont une amende
on parlait de fondamental chez kamel ça
représente quand même beaucoup de soucis
fait que l'on sait du bon enfin quoi
fait que moi je me suis moi joue pareil
je vais attendre la police vienne je
collaborais avec les autres si je veux
pas je le pourrai faire chier non plus
fait que se défendre de façon
sécuritaire responsable beau javel dans
4000 pieds carrés j'avais cinq stations
que j'étais comme si on vote accord on
prend les cinq premiers qui veulent
poursuivre le chemin du nord let's go
puis
je veux juste pour démontrer qu'être
cinquième de 4000 picard mêmes
personnes
desquelles abbas wing des step up et ils
vont faire des squats avec un ballon
puis des habs commence par un circuit de
30 secondes en 30 secondes off pour
souhaite un petit peu après son vol
juste nettoyées notre spot qui vont
partir l'après alors directement juste
de montrer que même si on était dans une
période où est-ce qu'on devait être
fermée qu'on peut faire de quoi avec la
pause axe nord avec la porte vaccinale
pipi l'on voulait démontrer aussi
l'iniquité entre les milieux les
restaurants sont fermés mais peuvent
faire du fast food les clean et qui sont
fermés mais tu peux prendre du privé en
physiothérapie massothérapie ensuite
fait pourquoi nous on pourrait pas le
faire non plus et continuer notre
mission dans la prévention de la
promotion de la santé c'est un peu ce
que je l'a démontré votre compte c'est
quand même ce matin j'ai posé mes côtés
l'assemblée je te plaît un peu là dessus
parce que je savais qu avant des
questions sur le sport
puis coach icaunais a lancé les
questions le masque noir qui souhaite
inciter n'ont pas de gameplay qui
démontre l incohérence en ce moment qui
existent au niveau de la démesure puis
la santé publique le docteur walo
lui-même s'est trompé hier avec ses
bordels type qu'on voulait vraiment
surligner se poser on est victime depuis
le début de votre cohérence puis ils ont
été créés j'interromps le podcast pour
parler de ma nouvelle compagnie eut pika
et de mon nouveau produit le pic à
endurance un mois vous le savez j'ai
fait du sport d'excellence pendant plus
de 20 ans puis c'est une affaire que je
négligeais c'était vraiment la nutrition
pendant l'effort des fois je faisais 20
heures d'entraînement dans piscine par
semaine puis je buvais que de l'eau
évidemment c'est loin d'être optimale le
pic à endurance c'est un tout en un pour
tous ceux qui pratiquent des sports
d'endurance donc vélo natation
kayak ski de fond boxe tout des sports
qui dura plus de 45 minutes en fait
c'est un tout en un pour votre
performance donc 25 g de glucides les
glucides c'est l'énergie dont vous avez
besoin pendant l'effort dans les 25 g de
glucides on a 16 g dextrine cycliques
qui est un glucide absorption rapide et
à vidange gastrique rapide donc ça tombe
pas sur le coeur parce que c'est dû
gérer rapidement ça rentre dans le
système pour vous donner l'énergie dont
vous avez besoin on a 300 mg de sodium
vous le savez le sodium ça aide la
rétention d'eau ça permet de rester de
ratés et de garder des fonctions
musculaires optimale pendant les sports
de longue durée on a un large profil
d'électrolytes pour remplir les réseaux
l'hectolitre que vous perdez pendant
l'activité physique puis on a un âge où
aussi de taurine et de vitamines b et c
est pour maximiser la création d'énergie
est évidemment l'endurance musculaire
honnêtement j'ai testé beaucoup de
produits autant dans ma carrière que
dans
ma deuxième carrière de coureur si on
veut avant de faire le piquet endurance
et 2c de loin de loin le meilleur de
tous je vous le jure évidemment je
prêche pour ma paroisse mais c'est pas
juste moi qui le dis parce que je les
fais testé à mes amis qui sont des
sportifs élite puis cas pas tout la
gagne trouve que c'est de l'or en barre
dans ce que le dollar en poudre
honnêtement ça vaut le coup si vous
l'essayez vous allez plus jamais pouvoir
prendre autre chose je vous le dis c'est
la bombe on a citron limon n'a pas un
show fruits en termes de savoir aller
voir pour plus d'informations ou
hippiques à point ses appuis si vous
m'écoutez en ce moment au d'histoire du
sans filtre podcast on a un code promo
pour vous qu il sans filtre 10 pour 10 %
de rabais sur toutes vos commandes du
picca point ca
honnêtement want you go epica you never
go back fake sur ce je vous laisse avec
les red la conversation avec m
mais un peu comme justement l'événement
qu'ils avaient vous peut-être un peu
inspiré que la boulangère aux
agnostiques sait et il m'avait parlé de
l'entrevue avec l'aga cicada dernier
puis je l'écouté cpie état est en furie
les épis toutes les liens internes et
puis tout les points qu'elle amène au
final toutes ces incohérences le cas
qu'elle apporte sont valides ces enfants
sont ces sa frustration elle est
compréhensible puis elle est légitime
mais donc c'est ça il y en a deux c'est
ce qui en a dans sa cité des
délits vols de même qui fait qu'il y ait
beaucoup lui le droit face aux mets ce
pot somme estimée bref dans cette
journée là donc c'est ce que vous avez
fait vous êtes entraînés à cinq pièces
que la police ait pointé en fait aux la
police on ne peut plus le faire parce
que dans le fond on attend d'avoir
l'accord du corps policier qui l'épaule
et on voulait parler les mettre en feu
on est quand même proche du service de
police du quartier on s'entraîne dehors
ils passent new wave ont la part belle
avec eux autres puis comme de fait est
un politique du québec et d'arrivée fait
16 ans que dans le quartier de villers
et puis
une voir la couverture puis le canal +
début puis
comme je vous comprends juste avec vous
mais on peut juste pas s'entraîner dans
votre mode homme je comprends pas de
problème on va continuer de
manifestations extérieures on a
collaboré si je l'aï dit plusieurs fois
si on veut pas faire les hors la loi on
a sorti notre flag pays de savoie paul
puis se fait qu'on est restés à
l'extérieur puis on avait une bonne
soixantaine de personnes soit 10
personnes avec des pancartes déguisé
j'avais une banane d'exil avec dj
est un bel hiver le fait que ce qu'on a
fait les dimanches le putois avec ta
prise de position
comme vous attend tous affirment en
chemin quand j'ai entendu toutes sortes
de messages de toutes sortes de monde de
toutes sortes de groupes positifs et
négatifs origines ouais c'est tout si
beaucoup de négatif j'ai toujours cette
partie le jeune qui parle avec émotion
picchi qui vous dit c'est un peu le jeu
avec quelqu'un qui me faisait 6 comme en
psychologie la chaise bleue qui ne
s'étudie kelly bleus mais comme nous
elle est verte de lé menu non à l'hiver
va qui ont poussé on doit ses soeurs
avec les panneaux acoustiques garou
tchèque
hongrie
comme l'écrivait jean
ce que tu fais ce mail passe puis
comme un marathon le agressif le pour me
dire que je suis dans le champ puis
s'effectue j'ai réussi je te disais
douzaine puis beaucoup violent la page
du gym en fait est-ce que vous avez avec
100 postes non en fait je pensais
vraiment d'actualité l'on n'a pas
réalisé que c'était un sujet aussi qu'il
n'est rejoindre les gens je sais pas si
ces gens plus une porte ouverte pour ces
gens là qui vont signer à chaque fois
qu'il voit quelque chose ou que vraiment
beaucoup de gens mais on a réalisé que
c'est vraiment problématique quand même
existantes et moins conscients d'être
puis sinon ce thème agir tellement des
gens qui était supporteur qui disait je
remercie de dire tout ce que les gens
pensent tout bas je lui plusieurs puits
beaucoup de gens qui travaillent dans la
santé drôlement qui me faisait un mode
chez
les gens qui sont leur travail ce que
nous aimons celle arrêt de travail je
t'ai tout cas pas j'ai pas eu de
vacances depuis deux ans je veux juste
roulé puis on ouvre thème je suis
capable sur la place que j'allais pour
me vider sa léo jim je peux puis allez
je suis capable
ma santé mentale mais on parle pas fait
que jugeant une bonne vingtaine de gens
de la santé qui était comme tu fais
tomber bien on est écoeuré on a besoin
de ce fait que cette fermeture est là
avec ce mouvement l'heure on dirait que
ça vraiment souligner le besoin au
niveau de la santé mentale les autres
c'était vraiment comme on finir les gens
n'étaient pas en forme je sais que mon
dieu ça fait mal mais là c'était
vraiment géré la fermeture la santé
mentale
s'être entraîné ses hôtes en prendre
soin de sa santé physique et mentale
tranquillement à parts égales puis je
suis aussi dans les dents le support que
tous reçus est-ce que tu as reçu du
support de gens
qui ont des causes auxquelles je peux tu
as aussi
à huawei est évidemment plus sait pas
c'est que les trackers étaient les
rockeurs qui manifestaient pour une
affaire plan mené ça devient le tout le
monde qu'ils jouaient presque pour vous
autres le faisaient pas avec moi le c5
et acrobatique est pas la bonne affaire
c'est fou je vais pas réalisé j'ai une
demande d'ami 2 2 alexis koessler
sans mon facebook claude que qui après
des enfants jamais trop patrie mais moi
ce que je ne pensais pas aller ok j'ai
fait déjà rage pense pas les leur projet
tht un des groupes de de gens qui ne
comprenaient pas trop là dessus je pense
qu' il checke et genre les sorties
justin trudeau qu'il va se passer ce qui
va se passer se
sortir de ce groupe ne dispose pas mon
job jusqu'au quiche au saumon ford
fait non j'ai eu quelques trucs de gens
que ce sont eux qui allaient m'emporter
là dedans a dû elle-même est juste pas
accepter les affaires mais parce que
c'est en ce moment là la grogne
populaire et partout le s'il y avait
quand même je pense plus que jamais
présentes qui forme et on way peas et
c'est ce qui est du monde qui ont vu ton
trip qu'en fait il fallait l'ouvrir pin
up il faut que la taxe
est tout ce que tu dis les gtc passe pas
ma bataille et je te dirai s'est passé
pas la bataille que je veux mener que je
reproche c'est un certain point je
comprends qu'il faut être drastiques
dans dans la lah dans l'opposition
thibaut monnet mais je pense que il faut
aussi être progressive dans son approche
mais je pense que les gens ont pu y ont
plus de patients sont toutes les
réflexions jusqu'en ils vont sud puis je
comprends je tiens la pulsion j'aimerais
quand même chose je peux juste pas
de cette façon-là dans les actions qui
vont pour pour la population c'est comme
moi ce que je faisais c'était vraiment
me lever pour les gens puis pour qu'on
puisse changent d'objectif qui est un
message fort lancé niveau politique
parce que je comprends qu'il faut qu'il
fasse cheminées sont au niveau politique
mais il y aurait il changé avec des fous
tu prends des positions drastique au
point de me dire à qui joue si pas de
passeport bls gauche je pense que
j'avais des plus sérieux malheureusement
avec la situation présente
pas pour toi faut que ton message tu le
fasses passé avec une cuillère de sucre
c'est l'expression spoonful schengen
pour faire une mauvaise nouvelle mais
ton soudain tout le temps un jardin tu
le laisse tranquille et adoucit mettons
comparution pour sa part estimé au début
on voulait ouvrir
forever commence et finit le puil on se
parlait j'ai parlé aussi avec le tien
regroupement
descendait consciemment physique qui
travaille au niveau politique écrivent
les lacs les députés tout faut pousser
les les massages en haut puis
ce qui me disant prends toujours pas
cela ne fait que jeter que moi un petit
bec
ce serait une bonne idée de faire une
journée symbolique à la place
puis c'est une protestation
au final pacifiste puis c'est ça
ça risque de conséquences le titre à
l'époque comme seule journée le tout de
vous donner la commune par exemple
[Musique]
je peux plus d'agents locaux school
dimanche paniagua vide ou gens mais
précise paul ahyi l'umih avec 5000
personnes à votre cap de sable tantôt
t70 sur la rue mais c'est ce qui qui tue
qui avec
parce que td des critiques mettons des
mesures et des critiques les décisions
du gouvernement il y en a de toutes
formes et de toutes parts de toutes
sortes la mettons qu'il ya un an que
j'attends justement quand tu entends je
parlais de la boulangerie de bain alors
peut-être raison d'être inquiet ce type
pis il y en a d'autres qui disent
d'affaires puis jeudi mais qu'elle dit
haute et puis c'est dur de faire le
ménage aussi pu d'ailleurs être capable
de qu'est-ce qui te critiquer mots qui
disent aussi critique valide puis c'est
vrai que telle et telle incohérence
versus qui lui est tombée tombés digues
dans le
conspuer puis j'ai l'impression que
aussi pour petits pour bien du monde
tout ce mélange pays où
c'est toi en fait la difficulté
voyageant par mimos et de
c je pense qu'ils émettront pour une
cause qui est qui qui moufte rocky
latine qui innovent vouloir promouvoir
l'activité physique je pense que c'est
important aussi de qui dans le message à
ce que la caisse que qu'est ce que tu
proposes qu'est-ce que tu cautionnes
pomme
[Musique]
[Rires]
est ce que tu veux dire dans le fond je
devrais être plus clair dans les
positions ou plus ou pas serment mais
moi je trouve que c'était assez clair
c'est que c'était pas lié à aucun enjeu
par rapport mettons que ce soit la
vaccination que ce soit les restrictions
de distanciation pelez les restrictions
les mesures sanitaires en fait parce que
fermer c'est quelque chose mais peu se
respecter les mesures center c'est
complètement autre chose je pense que
c'est assez clair à ton message que
c'était le but d'ouvrir mais en
respectant clairement les mesures
établies au maillot jaune était vraiment
en phase là dessus parce que justement
je savais que si on n'allait pas faire
mention en plus chaque route au niveau
des médias kitty charlotte à eux parce
qu'ils y ont vraiment été comme c'est ce
qu'ils vont essayer d'avoir les aides
les nuls le meilleur fajjar clic boom
pow wow est ce parce qu'ils aident les
nuls presspass des gens qui veulent
défier les règles qui moi à chaque
rentrée vue je dis tout le temps notre
oubli y est pas je ne suis pas hors la
loi respecte et supra les règles vous
allez voir puis je les rédiger tout
temps là dessus cela là on défie pas
nous autres on s'en va dans cette avenue
loeb ça va être pacifique à force j'ai
dû le dire et le redire puis de plus en
plus petits voyages précédents les
articles ont été écrits de ses acquis et
de promotion des activités physiques non
je suis quand même cool mais les
premiers du genre on va défier tout le
monde au puy c'est drôle parce qu'il
d'aider des sources médiatiques que
j'aurais cru qui a mis ce genre super
gentil cheesy pirate
bay ont pas été comme ce que je pensais
que la palette l'ont été comme ça selon
les sources mais en fait c'est aussi
dernièrement c'est vrai
dans ma vie qui est différent mais pas
seulement de ce que je me suis dit ils
vont démonter inversement y avait pu
écrire jobs good job la seconde faible
qui est cool
mais qu
est ce que vous pensez que c'est le même
temps - je me place en position et
mettons que je premier ministre québec
le hockey
décision
c'est sûr que dame mettons un plan que
je m'imagine joue les salles de
spectacle en même temps que les jim sont
là pour moi les deux sont
égaux en termes sont égales en terme de
priorité d'importance ce que vous pensez
mettons que
les preneurs de décisions justes par
leurs habitudes de vie qui ont dû
françois legault je sais pas quel point
il fait du sport le mais ne pas en faire
tant que sur mettons là si c'était plus
important dans sa vie c'était plus
important dans la vie ces gens le
savaient étaient plus importants dans
leur éducation dans la façon avec
laquelle ils ont été élevés qu'ils ont
appris à prendre soin de leur corps leur
santé est ce que vous pensez que ça
aurait pu influencer l'ordre de
réouverture ou du moins la gestion de
ces fermetures de ouais ça d'autres
bâtiments ont parlé aux joueurs si on
parlait du feeling quand tu reviens de
courir mettons le long 1 course piqué et
fait froid le titre take it off mettra
30 chez vous
puis l'espèce de feeling source à
l'intérieur tiki tellement
viscérale viscérale pu tellement
agréable tellement fort
piqué
on the expliquer à quelqu'un qu'il sait
pas qui s'est passé quoi ce feeling et
ckoi thil et le feeling d'art of tête de
tête dépasser les farines d'études
vraiment at elle expliqué m quelqu'un
qui va regarder
- void
les parents de paul et avec la barbe
plein de matchs et des sources de
relance et que sa course à pied spécial
dans l'espoir cardiovasculaire plus
de commandeur firme genre allumé puis
zen gens sont vraiment des fois on
cautionner un genre en 15 mais des fois
je sais pas où tu l'as dit chico
braindead mais quand c'est plus qu'un
différend feeling
bougent leur nez avec ça c'est que comme
disait dans tout nous on lui demande qui
font du spa depuis jeunes pis s'arrêter
quelques rapides max dans la vie c'est
comme c'est quelque chose qu'elle est
tout le temps être le de manière
régulière mais quelqu'un que possible
c'est de lui expliquer min siv est
tellement du bien jean certainement du
bien faire du pas opter qui le pot
véhicules tu peux pas comprendre que
sans doute que pour n'importe qui ça
influence ici sans se dégoter un
domaine le nouveau maire de québec qui
courent ça km par semaine avec nos
matches en se rangeant vrai
mais fête du triathlon
j'ai lu l'article de normand aux
marchands c'était quoi n'ont juste pas
c'est quoi la source lemay coureurs sur
l'heure du midi mais c'est sûr que lui
va être plus sensibles à ces agents qui
a fait des sorties après avoir du sport
ouais ouais ouais ouais il ya aussi fait
une sortie la semaine passée dans les
journaux pour disais justement que
l'importante activité physique insu
effective veulent pas si la plus
instruite
nos ministes ils font du sport je suis
que l'on sait que les ministres des
finances il est venu ici puis il joue au
hockey
c'est ça il faut que ça soit
gia jeu posé la question je me demandais
de c'est parce que je me doutais qu'on
avait parlé de ça aujourd'hui c'est que
j'ai posé la question à un ami qui est
toujours réponses à ces questions lors
qu'ils se remettant est ce que est ce
que le fait de faire du sport tel qu'on
ait une discussion là dessus mais je
veux juste avoir mais dont l'effet est
ce que le fait de faire du sport mettons
de manière régulière
me donne moins de risque de d'avoir des
complications sévères d'accueillir
d'attenté je m'excuse mais continue
sa réponse c'était il ya plein de
facteurs qui existera des complications
de l'aco vide ou non mais c'est sûr que
si tu as de bonnes habitudes de vie
dimanche bien du fait du port du réduit
ses chances d'aller à l'hôpital c'est
super la poignée pareil mais ça se peut
que ça soit moi je peux avoir des
occasions par qualifie pour la santé qui
est qu'ils sont morts
quand même
considérable conservatoire et risque
pileux je m'en allais qui port avait une
trajectoire en sang se passe a réduit
les risques de comas visiter ce qui est
des faits qui fait que ce soit le
que ce soit le buzz it et que ce soit le
diabète ce sont toutes ces affaires là
qui sont des qui augmente le risque de
développer des complications accueillir
évidemment tutu d'action ce genre mais
il m'a envoyé le lien vers une étude qui
a été fait naître térieur sur eux c'est
je pense à 40 mille participants sur
justement pour pour arriver à cette
conclusion le puits dans les
recommandations de l'étude ils disent on
recommande ou sociétés de santé publique
de recommander l'activité physique le
plus possible ou citoyen c'est comme un
outil de plus pour combattre la cavité
se
savait pas dire comme seul outil
évidemment ajouter parce que si ça
contribue un outil permettant depuis je
pense que moi personnellement puis comme
vins du monde l'outil promis
le plus efficace pour protéger la cage
vide c'est le vaccin et mettons
l'intérêt mais le fait de faire du port
le fait d'avoir des bonnes habitudes de
vie en général
ça désengorge
ouais ça pour ça pourtant ce messagerie
jamais envoyée mais par contre j'ai
aussi tu mets ton mot gdt sur facebook
on a tout du monde nautique est conçu
plus vraiment
pitt et je vois souvent des affaires
passées déjà
on parle de vaccins mais ce qu'on vous
dit pas aussi que une attention c'est un
ou telle affaire naturel vous protège
c'est que tu as peur le faire du sport
bien manger a vendu 27 titres de vie
tout seul ça aide mais genre ça ne
remplace pas d'autres solutions comme le
vaccin ne sais pas qui c'est pas un ou
l'autre c'est de 36 ans enlevé qui comme
société on se donne les meilleures armes
possibles pour battre ces sites a fallu
qui ne fait tout signé médecin
il faut juste toutes les prendre pippo
dire c'est ça ou se sait comme on est
ainsi tout ensemble c'est encore une
fois moi je pense que ça parce que y'a
j'ai fait une publication sur instagram
est pratique mais qui dit exactement sur
lorsque moi j'ai j'ai fait une story en
allant faire vacciner plus je me suis
fait d'envoyer un message quand pourquoi
tu fais la promotion du vaccin mais pas
des saines habitudes de vie alors que
mon contenu instagram ce n'est que du
sport c'est la vie je
suivais gagnent mais je fais du sport ce
n'est que ce que je partage lorsque peu
fier du fait d'une application dix ans
j'aurais fossé comme il faut tout
prendre ce compte qui nous est offert
pour lutter contre tout puis je pense
que c'est vraiment comme dans tout de
même une minorité bruyante qui vont être
pas être capable de saisir ce message là
c'est son c'est une minorité mais ils
font tellement crise le bruchec s'étudie
y cherche une douzaine de messages de
marc de l'été mais c'est peut-être
qu'ils étaient 15 à penser ce qu'il y en
a d'autres et on écrit
j'ai eu dans ma vidéo si je parle
justement bombay les dangers de six mois
je me suis je dois aller vraiment
dangereux les ténèbres loti jeter comme
m hervé s'est jetée comme l'obésité chez
les enfants et les adolescents le banc
faut plus jamais les fêtes leur j'ai eu
je crois qu'elle faisait référence mais
je peux se loue ni moins qu lequel
certains vidéo en disant on peut se
parler de sédentarité
fait que c'est juste prendre le temps
moi ma position par rapport à ça parce
que oui il faut pas l'utiliser sauf que
faut l'utiliser certaines fois c'est
dans le sens où moi je suis exemple dans
le front le fait que
de base est un mot qui existe qui peut
être utilisé moi je moi quand je dis
quelque chose quand je t'offre rompuy je
vois quelqu'un qui rentre puis qui me
verbaliser dis moi mon objectif c'est
comme si ch et 400 livres puis je veux
perdre du poids parce que je fonctionne
pull mais ils vont justement pour le
garde en plus moi tu ne peux pas te
cacher ses réseaux sociaux à wayne isham
frais banana café véhicule ça fait vécu
juste avec un monde ancien s'est jamais
remise ancien boss on m'avait engagé
dans une compagne d'entraînement puis en
face de la formation puis tous sont
repartis à eau à saint martin puis je
voudrais le centre d'entraînement en
matinée moi je suis un fou je bouge tous
les jours fait confiance à notre note
peu de formations maintenant au jim au
big band swing lendemain matin on se
lève mon affaire un chewing gum tree
endettés et les optiques prendre fin de
semaine off tu fais quand même mais je
veux être prêt à n'importe quoi dans la
vie le fait que ça fait partie de mon
bonbon mais ma vie
je veux ce temps là ils étaient quand
même présents ces pics à l'empêcher
d'aller à la plage adéquate avec nous
autres puis de se déplacer puis la pluie
était mal à l'aise avec sap et le
malheureux x il était mal avec ceux qui
me le verbaliser fait que si jamais
verbalisé j'ai applaudi le il faut
forcer son objectif s'il est un disciple
celui trouve qui est en santé parfait
parce que la santé ciss et un état de
bien être exact défini comme ça c'est là
la clé la clé de cet argument leur
espèce de faux débats autour de la kespa
de faux des baumes et de la question du
poids ce que la santé et pas juste le
passé seuls points principalement
après ça reste quelque chose qui existe
exactement moi je parle à la chose qui
existe qui était inquiète m
problématique pour l'être humain qui
puisse me verbaliser motion paul fait qg
du gard vient mon sens l'entraînement on
vas t'entraîner vient-elle cours on va
être deux piliers comment c'est arrivé
mais n'y avait pas là pendant les yeux
puis la peur du jugement la part de
toutes les parties
de se faire juger et et puis finalement
il est venu puis commencer trois quatre
cinq fois semaine il dit bien perdu du
poids
c'était ça son objectif puis maintenant
il rendu a perdu jean 125 livres publiés
comme cette année c'est mon été et pis
j'ai rendu mon abbas annoor santé non
centre d'entraînement de ces jeux les
mines amont sur mon site les
ambassadeurs santé bengue puis
c'est ce fait que c'est vraiment une
belle histoire de quelqu'un qui avait ce
problème le puis voilà que je pense
qu'ils en deviennent notes d'autres
personnes qui font ça aussi on n'est pas
obligé de le patch est partout non plus
mais je pense que c'est à l'autre
extrémité du continuo meilleur exemple
l'anorexie mais on peut en parler aussi
c'est une problématique faut que je
pense qu'il faut arrêter de juste comme
ne put dire les mots faut en parler
correctement il faudrait définir fait
c'est quand je parlerai définition c'est
gentil qu'accompagne mc il m'a dit de
masse corporelle c'est la bullshit
monsieur bmc dansante et puis quelqu'un
qui qui qui va être en obésité 2 mais
qui marche bien qui va faire un peu
d'activité physique puis qu'il s'est
remis dans sa peau peinte en santé je
pense que ce problème soit juste
redéfinir ce que chacun des camps au
temps des gens qui sont contents il n'y
en a pas la définition nous revoyons nos
définitions ensemble pour qu'on soit
capable de parler la même façon puis
dans le milieu de l'entraînement mon art
est d'accès non plus tout sur jean la
mairie sur la piste et ça suffit le sait
pas si la personne avions peuvent être
en santé père veut bouger par façon trop
fort semaine on n'avait rien c'est une
mère vit peut-être plus en santé plus
fonctionnel on a gagné si tu me le
verbalisent c'est autre chose mais il
faut qu'on arrête de axer notre travail
là dessus c'est certain c'est nous qui
nous ce sujet là on laborde somme toute
quand même fréquemment sur le podcast
puis à chaque fois qu'on parle télécom
ce que tu viens de dire leur moi je suis
tout à fait en accord avec ce que tu me
dire le pi
par le passé qu'on avait une
conversation nuancées comme si on
sortait en nous traitant grosso fob ou à
l'erreur sur youtube sur un cinglant
c'est pendant que nous on a une
conversation nuance in même où est ce
que l'on se fait traiter de grosse pas
parce qu'on est en conversation nuancé
tu vas l'épicerie puis le genre un
magazine avec comme 14 truc minceur pour
perdre du poids genre que cure de jus
vert pour atteindre votre poids votre
poids santé c'est comme ça c'est
problématique en table problème ni le
problème ici pendant une conversation
est ce qu'on est ce qu'on est très de la
santé qu'on essaie de
l'unikis je pense que quand même une
bonne
qui a une bonne vision du truc qui
l'expriment vraiment bien qu'ils
viennent pas un podcast justement autour
de la culture de dieppe puis de
commencer néfastes de ces choses là de
parler de sédentarité 100% c'est de
lutter contre la sédentarité
chu à fond la banque faisait accès oui
je suis d'accord avec ça on peut parler
de sédentarité puis
la pression et qu'on les conséquences
réaliser on s'en fout somme toute faite
luttons contre la sédentarité a promis
contacté ce ça produit toutes ces
pathologies y ait ces problèmes là qui
vont aller de ce que j'avais identifié
le que ce soit un avc que ce soit jean
l'obésité institut mais c'est ça je
pense que c'est un sous produit qui faut
pas éliminer non plus c'est parce que je
veux pas
fait cocasse mais qui verrait un fait
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité où sur la planète voir des
gens qui sont ce qu'ils sont comment
dirais-je pas dit s'il est mauvais
termes mais le poids corporel est plus
élevé que et plus de gens avec un poids
corporel un poids santé plus élevé que
le nombre de gens qui meurent de faim
sur la planète fait qu'il y ait beaucoup
plus de gens qui sont qui sont qui sont
ces consultations si on veut gens comme
j'aime le taire bien le terme
comparativement gens du monde sont aussi
mauvais aliments fait que comme on a
quand même quelque chose d'ici là
quelque chose qui fait qu'ils aient
quelque chose à manger
quand j'ai entendu que quand je les lui
a fait jeter comme un moment on a
quelque chose à faire
c'est ça vient avec notre mode de vie
c'est sûr c'est tout et industrialiser
tout va vite tout est fait que tu
travailles le moins de six puits monde c
est là que j terre prêt affecté là
dessus j'étais là tu me dit c'est comme
comment nos grands parents vivaient
leurs épaules mais le monde est en santé
pas mal plus que maintenant certains
points ce que ces six ans pendant les
années où je ne sais pas on n'attendait
pas tout l'accessible on avait moins de
six heures ouais c'est sûr traitement
aussi ouest je me dis des fois je rends
toi dans ton de mes grands-parents
sociale à l'école et aller au travail à
pied je vois là a pu aussi le travail
des fois et puis tout cette mentalité là
qu'on essaie tout d'avoir une
accessibilité à tout soit facile je
prends mon choix pour aller partout je
prends les escales électrique tout est
fait pour qu'on soit moins santé fait
que je pensais un lien excessif de quoi
fin ça fait ça fait aussi
ça ramène ça au cercle de
de l'ouverture d' agent a prises de
position dernièrement parce que je si
mon sport c'était pas la course à pied
tu pendant bottes on faisait des
trainings de genre de vidéos youtube
genre de vidéos youtube dry land de bade
et white pour appartements jacques ce
genre d'affaires le puits si ma vie
avait été de travailler du bureau
puisque tout le monde est en télétravail
puis de m'entraîner chez nous de
travailler chez nous puis de vivre chez
nous de dormir chez nous me réveillais
de rester chez nous là j'ai eu la chance
d'être bête de faire la course à pied
puis de que ce soit en sport que
j'apprécie que j'aime faire avec shorts
et de chez nous sortir de chez vous veut
veut pas ça te demande de faire cesser
un reset dans ta tête
fait que d'aller aux jeans c'est plus
que juste à les faire ton je parle donc
d'un entraînement sort de chez vous tu
vois du monde mais vous salue à d'autres
exercent et quand même quelque chose si
c'est moi mettons depuis que
depuis que je fais du crossfit serait
quand même longtemps ça va faire un 4 5
1 des revenus de taiwan a longtemps pu
référence temporelle que juste nous y
comptons
le moment avant que c'est la façon
d'un quartier qui
ya pas une fois qu'ils émettront juge
j allais
vraiment leur tige à qui ça a tout pour
que j'y aille loin versus quand je me
fais des entraînements par moi même
parce que depuis depuis deux ans c'est
beaucoup sur facebook sont motivés par
toi même c'est beaucoup trouver des
vidéos youtube le feu rouge à vous faire
un world est qu un d'ambelle tout seul
chez eux mais c'est moins le fun quitté
des moments où est ce que je
me suis pas entraînée parce que chez les
symptômes troppo ou que ça prend tout
pour le faire ça arrive bien plus
souvent que me déplacer pour aller au
gym qui est de la gagne qui est là quel
coach juste juste avant comme si c'est
tantôt d'abord quelqu'un qui te dit quoi
faire
parce que moi je peux être est ce peut
être une dernière la wii fraîche et
d'aider ou
[Musique]
mais si aujourd'hui je
fais je pense que type n'est plus bon
pour moi c était ce la chose qui était
au point exigeant pour moi à faire comme
activité physique il y en a pour qui
c'est là qu'il y en ait pour qui sait
tout à faire tousser la course et
surtout de programme
j'ai payé une coach privé une quine qui
me fait mon programme malade fait lui
même je me lève le matin et puis j'ai
même pas besoin de penser à ckoi je fais
c'est fait je ne la connais tu sais quoi
elle s'appelle catherine garnier ouais
je ne sais coquine coureuses qui se
marre à
picot cg keane sur instagram
juste
chacun doit trouver je pense son truc
sont exotiques fait que comme non
seulement tu vas bouger mais s'attendent
ya les bretons du fonds dans le forez et
puis que ce soit la cour mais le pour
qui la course il ya ici pour mourir ou
qui ont m'allonge lymphatique équipe
corpo puis ceux qui ont trouvé
en ce moment ceux qui ont trouvé ce
se met dans les jeans exactes sont
pénalisés
versus ceux qui ont trouvé seul dans la
course soudain c'est exact
exactement
pour pour revenir à la à la question de
la sédentarité est ce que moi j'ai connu
du monde qui étaient sédentaires mais
qui avait l'air d'athlète c'est comme
cave alors qu'ils avaient le leu leu en
guillemets puisque cette expression l'a
absolument mal vieilli le mec avait le
big board il repiquait sauf que qui
étaient les personnes avec le lien de
vie la plus nocive
renault fait que les problèmes
étaient souvent plus d'ordre manteau ou
d'ordre
juste comme de de nutriments le trident
talent de la santé mes médecins pour
dire que cette identité là se déclinent
plus que juste dans le pur comme on
parlait trop facile de se racheter ce
n'est pas parce que c'est plus visible
que personne ida
d'entendre santé
des athlètes comme seuls outils des
jeunes athlètes leon 23 ans chez p la
digos puis ça mange du mcdo vias couche
tard puis ça revient bien performé
tout comme cela il battait tout le monde
est commencé ces personnes 12 12 caritas
équipe à expérience je peux dire qui est
à 23 sa marche en 30 matches mais ouais
c'est parti le lithium le vent froid qui
équivaut à faire le sam est différent on
voit que ça va donner puis ben ouais
effectivement tu pourrais tu peux avoir
l'air super en forme petit les postes
sinon beaucoup d'exemples comme ça sur
les essais grand oui et oui mais oui
mais oui je titre ça m'a fait penser
quand il était plus jeune des fois on
faisait les nuits blanches à gainey à
l'ordinateur puis on partait du mobile
et du monde tout ce qu'elle s'appelait
le dream city c'était à 5 fois c'était
en bas de la côte
ou à côté de la petite grenouille ça une
fois côté de l'after
[Rires]
quand j'arrive à québec dans le fond moi
j'avais 20 ans et puis le jeter dans les
résidences du reste et lavage j'ai pogné
celle pour gow 1 re manche en sommes à
côté des toilettes sous sol c'était
dégueulasse ce genre de broyage tard la
boj tecmo qui s'est souvent faite sur
mon expérience d'augusta la bonne
direction les bords tous ceux qui non je
veux faire de quoi je veux aller à
l'université je suis capable d'afficher
reste ici je veux construire des lyrics
mitchum pigeot fini
je sais pas les bords encore david sait
rien contre ça c'est juste que je
voulais faire de quoi des significatif
au niveau du sport la santé tout sorti
je me demandais une correction à québec
les personnes
qui la première personne que je
rencontre sont mes cours puis il pose
une question où les chinois
aussi bien
que je me rapproche collègues deviennent
outre ils se disent ils le ch comme les
inzko la barbade
c'est la première fois que j'entendais
l'accent kadin ma vie j'étais comme moi
j'ai entendu ça de ma vie avec mon club
ludovic est devenu mon bébé gorille
adversité on habitait dans la même
résidence puis la première fois concert
québec c'est les deux rondes et saint
alban à côté l'avancé les pubs en bol
gros clubs
norbord grenon c'était un boss
descendait la khl à la lazio le
palladium le pas la wii un parfait on se
dirait qu'ils ont faim palladium ça y
est nous est allé j'avais 17 ans je
t'aime
tellement
comme et comme réputé le banc qui s'est
rempli mineurs plions une idée sans
doute après six ans a fini par faire la
fête là on arrive on a connu une
descente tout moi je me dis acquis moi
je m'arrêterai puis ludo lui ni moi je
construis faire la porter avec lâcheté
commun et un after je suis le même vécu
ce don effectué lundi on se lève
le cross du people in the et l'after la
rentrée puis l'accueil il m'a dit ouais
voici votre souffle il y avait des jeux
un ordinateur
régule pas c'est bien la route et ça
maintenant et à canal enfin bon
si c'est bon ailleurs il existe chez
canon le donna la victoire de la musique
le monde dans ce pays ces dix ferrals
également par un fils c'est assez bien
joué qu'est
[Rires]
ce que c'est bon cheval pkk contre huit
qui avait du monde qui rend très
clairement sur le mode de partage où il
rentrait pour aller pisser parce que
j'en avais trop une file en beauf qui
rentrait dans ce drôle jouer on les
regarde et nous regarde et on ne
comprenait pas
mais ouais c'est nous autres des fois on
faisait ça on faisait la nuit blanche
pions en partie du dream pour aller au
peps de l'université laval puis pour
s'entraîner à 5 heures pour faire un
deux orientations qui ont été corrects
on le dépose des panneaux meilleur jour
n'est monté que rec le genre je repense
à ce aujourd'hui avec klose bij mougenot
remonte aux pères
[Rires]
après ceux ci mettons ces jours ci avec
le temps qui passe pilorge qui arrive
dramatique aura je
pense vraiment que je fasse plus
attention tu mets ton le jeu sur une
longue période sans alcool le juste
parce que ça comme a donné une longue
période sans alcool puis c'est comme les
matins ils sont plus mots tout comme
plus clair puis on dirait que tu es puis
je vois pas ne plus jamais à reprendre
parce que j'ai pas de problème de
consommation mais maintenant boire de
l'alcool je me réveille le lendemain il
même si je prends une ou deux bières le
lendemain à tête dans le cul
l'entraînement et - loge je peux un peu
déprimé comme l'hygiène de vie c'est
tellement
tu réalises ce vraiment plus en
vieillissant j'imagine parce que avant
tu peux tu tu t'es capable de s'en
sortir avec des estives viennent de
marde mais ça dure pas
puis drôlement d'encre au streaming
c'est je parlais de ce avec des boxeurs
se mentir les autres ils peuvent arriver
peuvent arriver
dont vous ai pris deux ou trois bières
et pas fait attention à son alimentation
par vivo boxer point de bonnes bonnes
séances techniques tant
pis nous n'achetons notre sport repose
entièrement sur les nutriments justement
que consommer ses tontons niveau
d'énergie pitou fectivement que des prix
jean reno d'hubert ressenti lundi mois
fait que notre sport est comme extra
sensible à ce fait quand d'autres n'ont
même pas de tuer même chose en natation
est clair qu'on s'appelle sam soit à
manger une poutine en place de deux
corps baup lundi pendant que certains
veulent c'est vraiment facile de le de
taille mais ces annotations en mettant
le terme étant les lego d'accueil
peuvent sortir un soir rien qu'ils sont
à las vegas faire la peau de bee ware
puis le lendemain ils peuvent creuser un
peu dingue n va avoir une grosse game
mais quelqu'un s'en rendent pas compte
quand le lendemain matin son coach le
chrono de même si comme
pour coter points trois de plus lent que
d'habitude si calme on
peut le voir les tcc directement avec
moi je te fais là dessus siècle la
jussie l'on récupère - moi je m'entraîne
des fouaces après 48 ans est la vôtre
sentir aux gens me squatter de jours non
pas comme ça avant l'arrêt de
ces genres deux jours plus tard si vous
aussi oui j'arrive que d adapter
complètement ma classe la plus longue
je peux mettre autant de l'autre que je
m'étais avant qu'ils aient voir
l'entraînement il change aussi c'est
pour ça que des carrières comme tom
brady ou genre lebron james s'est
tellement impressionnant c'est que
d'autres c'est que là ils durent
tellement longtemps c'est un but qui
vient de prendre sa retraite 45 des
incroyants bien là la vengeance a l'air
d'avoir doigt c'est sam max c'est encore
un des meilleurs outils c'est fou par
les autres c'est parce qu'ils se font
tellement qu'investir l'accord faut
tellement qu'ils prennent soin de leur
corps mais en même temps c'est la preuve
que tu prends soin de ton corps pas
vraiment de raison que ça s'arrête
parce que des fois dans le film tu avais
comme des des images de lui back des
meilleurs jamais vie parce qu'il ment
jamais il tire une photo d'eux
explique régis
même pas mais
en fait je pensais 22 ans qui fait
danser à sa carrière au complet 22-22
saison lui ont pris son raid chaude
toutes les saisons puis ils l'ont mis
dans un espèce de montage en 30 secondes
qui
non mais au milieu de sa carrière il ya
l'air a mis à l'arrêt comme prendre un
coup de vieux plat mais on dirait qu'il
tend maintenant fontaine de jouvence me
plaît à rodez les gens appeler arvier
viallard plus jeunes qui faute et puis
maintenant battre
alors chaque plat mais il est tombé
quelque chose
commence est immature
fait les jam réouvrant doucement
doucement voici la ceco exposé pour toi
écoutant ce moment d'ici là on va
rapatrier l'équipement qu'on a prétendu
membre pour s'entraîner ok vous aviez
prêter
fonds prêtés l'équipement de l'aider
comme le second est parti fait qu'on va
rapatrier ménages fond en comble au
niveau je te dirais le thème des
politiques qui avaient déjà leurs
groupements justement la fille qui
travaille avec des campagnes médiatiques
poussé le message niveau politique mois
j'aime manger embarqué dans le mouvement
pour faire une opposition drastiques
pour avoir un message je suis conscient
et les supporter et
puis on verra ce que ça donne aux
prochaines élections moi c'est ce que ça
va changer maintenant je ne sais pas
mais tout se continuer ce combat
dans le fond je restais année de plus en
public parole est exactement puis on
avait avec la pandémie justement j'avais
comme creek que certaines petites
affaires puisque je me suis dit le
problème en eau gire est pas en
politique pour essayer de faire quoi que
ce soit des gens qui sont malades d'un
puits qui aiment sur moi ça m'intéresse
pas tant que ça mais je pense que dans
tout changement commence par changement
le local fait que j'ai comme qui dirait
certains petits trucs qui vont
développer graduellement on a parti la
fédération d'entraînement fonctionnel
sportif l'ex de fédérations sportives
qui régit notre sport parce que dans le
fond c'est crossfit sont présents c'est
comme la boxe professionnelle les sports
professionnels et crossfit games tout ça
on vous laisse faire l'argent à genk
nous autres on va s'occuper du sport
amateur au québec fait qu'on a vraiment
développé là la structure d'accueil pour
développer l'initiation récréation
compétition on a fait une saison à
l'instant t elle et son entraînement se
sont ils paient un abonnement prêtre
clubs sportifs et que l'on de 65 clubs
sportifs 400 membres fait que l'on va
déposer nos documents prêts très connu à
travers et sports québec convoi
s'asseoir avec la natation québec avec 1
du québec puis c'est à être pris au
sérieux dans l'export la créance édition
fait ce qu'on est capable de développer
le volet initiation puis rentre dans les
écoles c'est dommage commence une équipe
de cloche chez nul à laval high school
jeudi j'ai 36 ans je m'en vais coché
quatre 4 kits de 13 à la justice on y va
on y va on va pelleter on va mettre les
mains dans boot ses excès on peut
développer ça partout québec puisqu'elle
les jeunes justement deviennent
compétents fassent ce qu'ils font sur
cinq ans mais il finit second doit bien
précis qu'est ce qu'il va faire il faut
aller dans le club sportif concentré à
100 sa vie du fait que je me suis dit si
on y va de cette façon là on va financer
l'achat d'acier
puis l'on développé aussi un obnl qui
s'appelle club le grand v on offre des
séances d'entraînement gratuite club le
grand club legrand vice et des séances
d'entraînement gratuite aux jeunes de 14
à 19 ans notre quartier de cartes
historiques arctique quand même
défavorisés si on dans le secteur qui
favorise et métis et injuste recadre la
terre de quelques rues des places plus
vers l'ouest c'est
agréable
bonne population jeune et qui équipe
plus démunis si on entend parler aussi
justement les actualités de nam ha oui
ce qu'on veut faire justement c'est leur
offrir gratuitement on sent
d'entraînement puis avoir des spots
d'une heure par jour ce qui peuvent
n'effectuerait qu on met des liens avec
leurs autres avec le collège ahuntsic
bientôt un organisme communautaire crec
nous autres qui vous venez fait que on
se presse prête de word on développe ce
par en dessous ce qu'on veut faire c'est
faire des franchises sociale puis de
donner notre plan d'affaires à d'autres
personnes vous à faire un autre club en
vue dans la zone d'entraînement sont pas
en avoir un dans chacun des noms
seulement tu peux revenir s'entraîner
comme de fait m faveur des kits du
quartier qui vont venir à peu près là où
qu'on appelle cela le sens de l'oise et
vous féliciter mon sens les oiseaux
c'est mon jeans fait que je pense que il
ya deux
semaines six pieds tout temps voulu
faire ça c'est tout le temps était assez
difficile de le développer l'ont fait
parce que modibo avec les écoles il
existe quand même des bonnes chasse
gardée il y en a beaucoup qui veulent
que ça reste à l'école mais nous on n'a
pas d'argent c'est gratuit touche mieux
à l'école c'est sauf que c'est difficile
mais sinon c'est ce qu'ont qu'on
développe puis avec ce qui s'est passé
je lui dis à plusieurs personnes on veut
faire le 30 janvier de la journée là des
salles d'entraînement sur le stage avec
des gros pari à chaque année dans chacun
de son entraînement juste pour célébrer
la vie pile entraînements et quand vous
commencez avec ça qu'on va continuer à
envoyer dit fier des événements qui vont
tout le temps de fêtes le dans la joie
place élaboration pour pour mettre de
l'avant l'importance
l'art entraînement pin notre rôle dans
la société ce que clairement il est
passé n'est pas assez compris
fait des petites actions locales qui je
l'espère vont se multiplier au cours des
prochaines années pour développer ce
mandat local pour changer global ah
ouais j'aime ça
[Rires]
merci infiniment
c'est à vous qu'il ya
du contenu excellent tu as tout un
podcast combien
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur une pétillante répétions vous
abonner pour trop dollars par mois c'est
trop de longs mois et trois pièces par
mois l'as par mois et vous avez les pas
de carte en avance acquise avec les
premiers de votre groupe d'amis avoir
quitté les podcasts puisse avoir pouvoir
avoir une avance quand vous allez tirer
la dynamique entre les amis sultan avons
une avance sur les jobs en avance les
entre deux toits mais avec pétillante
une avance sur l'humanité complète en
plus en plus parce que le ch et le
podcast unis voulaient nous entendre
josé davantage on fait des encore moins
de filtres après chaque pas de castaic
là on vient de finir de tourner le
podcast on vend jaser on va être pile et
nicole non nicole il est maintenant
évident comme un fils travaille à plat
ce détail est là mais on jase on parle
de conversion qu'on m'aide à voir mais
ce si vous voulez avoir accès sur
ben heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pétillant il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous